uh yeah
okay so uh welcome everyone to uh
the spring term in the
new technologies and mathematics uh
seminar series
so this semester we'll be having uh
more of a focus on ai and theorem
proofing as is uh
you know if you saw my talk at the cmsa
last
february or from many other places that
you know
interactive uh theorem improving is
becoming a more and more
interesting and potentially valuable
tool for mathematicians and if we could
combine it with ai that would perhaps be
the most revolutionary of the many
technologies that we've talked about for
how people actually do mathematics
and uh we're fortunate to have
joseph urban give us a introduction to
it so josof
is uh one of the leaders in this field
he's a pi and uh two major
collaborations in europe
on the subject and he's also the founder
of the leading conference in midfield
which is also called
aitj and uh so we're delighted to
invite you to speak thanks michael
it's an honor to to be at your
seminar and this is
as usual with my talks untested
and i i want to give you quite a few
demos so
let's see how it goes let's get into it
this is the ambitious
overview so i will quickly do some
motivation
i will not go too much into form math
because mike said that you
you will have more intro deeper
interactions into
formal math and i will mostly focus on
the various ways how we
combine typically some machine learning
and some theorem viewing
tools and what
what it can be divided into is sort of
high level
reasoning items called premise selection
and
that relates to tools called hammers
that are really
uh used uh especially in the isabel
system uh quite a bit then
low-level guidance of theorem previous
where you really guide
possibly very
fast theorem theory by
a machine learner you you are guiding
the inferences of of those systems
by hopefully hopefully fast uh machine
learning tools
and then something in the middle that i
call the mid-level reasoning guidance
which is for example guiding of the
tactical theorem driving systems like
let's say hole and coke where
it makes a lot of sense to to focus on
that level
and i will mention some uh so
i will try to mention some uh sort of
interesting
stuff going on with neural networks such
as
using neural networks for guiding
and especially synthesis and
conjecturing
and i will try to say something about
automated formalization
so basically using something like
machine linguistic machine translation
to translate
informal mathematics to formal
mathematics where
we can sort of play play
the automated reasoning game so
so this this is my very high level
introduction
which is the the the sort of
most ambitious motivation is
that we would like to sort of somehow
automate what mathematicians and
scientists are are doing and
we sort of know that that includes
all sorts of inductive reasoning like
analogizing
induction from examples pattern matching
but we also know that especially in
mathematics
and other hard sciences uh deductive
reasoning
and really finishing your proofs is
important and we
there are all these feedback loops
between that so between
these two two sides of
what we call thinking i guess
and uh we would basically try to
experiment with that on computers uh
so um so i long ago i
i have decided that formal mathematics
is a is a really nice playground for
doing that because you have a lot of
data you have a lot of
corpora and knowledge
from which you can learn by all sorts of
machine learning
methods but you can also really
do deduction you can see when something
is proved
you can and and because these systems
are
very secure exactly for for the need of
the like secure verification of the
proofs you
you know that when you find a very
unusual proof it's typically still a
proof unless you have a
bug in your system which really doesn't
happen
too much uh so so it allows you to
to do uh a lot of like deductive for
learning guiding deductive exploration
and we don't know
where it takes us but it's a it's a cool
cool area to experiment with and
hopefully
to to sort of develop systems that
help mathematicians and i don't know
computer scientists etc
with their reasoning
or their tasks so
for formal question when you make
synthesis do you mean like a program
synthesis
oh so
yeah but yeah it's better for you to
answer later it's fine i
just want you to ask um it's
it's you can think of it as program
synthesis
so i will give some examples where
for example you you have a set um
and you want to find uh the offentine
equation
that characterizes that set or you have
a lambda expression
and you why you want to find a
combinator expression that
results in in that lambda expression so
you
you could in my general comment on the
relation between
let's say programming and
like algorithms and mathematics and
reasoning
is that reasoning is bigger
programming is more specialized but
also more industrially important
and like the people who do reasoning
quite quite often
consider programming like a special part
of reasoning for for example
hank bartendreck who is one of the big
guys in
naimahan working at some pointless type
theory and cook system and wonder
calculus
uh likes to think about as the
combinations of the sort of algorithmic
part
and and the reasoning part where the
sort of algorithmic part
is sort of automated and the reasoning
part is the human input
but for for me as more of the reasoning
guy
i i would say that the tasks we are
trying to solve
are sort of super set of the tasks that
the programming people are solving
but obviously that's my point of view
like they might
have the other point of view
so formal math as i said i will not go
deep into it
but probably many of you know that
that there is this succession of people
like leibniz fager russell hilbert
gaddle church who
who basically came with
putting math on on formal
logic foundations which
by the way also led to to the rise of
computers
and that
in my opinion that that's really one of
the biggest things that happened in the
in the last century and we
we are still like reaping the benefits
and for example what i'm doing is really
heavily relying on the fact that
mathematics
has been formally
embedded into into logic and we can
really
play with mathematics like with a
computer game today
so so formal math is exactly this
uh people took this seriously in let's
say 50s or
more like 60s these people like the
brain milder
triple s boyer and uh mike gordon
gerard larry paulson and they created
all these systems like
automath lcf mizar and yusum
acl2 hol coke isabel
etc where they they really tried to
formalize mathematics and they
they really progressed uh so
in in the beginning
or let's say in the last decade or two
there have been really large
verification pro
projects like the verified the fly spec
project the execution of the
formal proof of the conjecture the
four color theorem the auto order
theorem
uh so verification of all sorts of
industrially important projects like
uh verification of compilers of
operating system microkernels
so it's it's really
becoming more and more
real more and more usable both for
mathematicians and for
industry basically and the
the formal math like this is i think
borrowed
from toms tom hiles's
uh talk at the burbakist seminary is
really conceptually very simple
so you you write your axioms and
theorems in a
sort of parsable computer understandable
way like basically you
invent a programming language for that
and
you define your and then
you just use the computer that your
crews follow follow the rules the
inference rules
so so it looks really simple but
it's it's not
simple in practice because of the
cognitive gap
between how computers work and how human
mathematicians work so one one guy
called it the high temperature and
low temperature so so i i would say that
a lot of what what was happening in the
formalization
field was going from the low temperature
to to something that allows you to
to do more steps or bigger steps
in uh in one command for example so that
that's the sort of technical
theorem viewing uh for
ai and theorem improving uh
like i have i have this uh
long talk at agi 18 which you can click
on
so there is a lot of interesting history
uh and also tension between
like the intuition based people
and the formerly oriented people so i i
always
have this picture from logic comics
where poincare
argues with hilbert and
like there is this tension between them
where one
doesn't like formalism and the other one
believes that it's the future and
uh basically turing is a very
interesting guy because
in his he proved the undecidability
right like he
defined the halting problem etc but
uh he also like in the 1950s he
basically invented
artificial intelligence or started
artificial intelligence
and in his 1950 paper on the turing test
and the computer
intelligence he basically ends the paper
with speculation about learning machines
like how how would you train
a computer to play chess so it's it's
sort of a very visionary and
um it goes really in the ai
direction a lot and uh
we were just talking with mike douglas
about
pat langley working on the coupler laws
so so
[Music]
there is doug leonard's work on the
automated mathematician and euresco so
so
these are things that were happening i
think in the 70s and 80s where
people were coming up with various
sort of symbolic approaches to uh
to do ai for science basically uh
what sort of started the the field
in which i am sort of working
at least for me is this very
in the late 90s by a group
in munich jericho dan singer
and stefan schultz and other people and
[Music]
they they really started to do to
explore machine learning
for automated theorem improving like
they had this
paper or technical report uh learning
from previous
uh proof experience and
that's really very interesting reading
even today like they
suggest many many things there
in my long ago master thesis i
i was very ambitious and i was trying to
use inductive logic programming this ilp
to basically learn explainable rules and
programs and heuristics
from from large mathematical
formalizations
and that was really an attempt that was
doomed to fail for all sorts of reasons
but it also gave me a lot of
i would say insight or feedback like
what
what needs to be done and
like i would say that since something
like
the 2000 the
we have started to use this large formal
or big proof corpora based on these
systems like mizar isabel and all
one coke to to play the game to
to to do various machine learning and
theorem
improving in this large libraries and to
combine
the two two things and
i i wanted to also mention like
for for many especially newer people
ai typically there is a confusion
between what is ai what is machine
learning and what is deep learning so
for some people
ai means deep learning today so if you
if you want to get more into it i
recommend this
ben garrotson stalk vanguard is one of
the fathers
of the artificial general
intelligence conference and
he he makes nice explanations
in the talk so so so the big ai visions
are
the one side of that like we would like
to automate verify
math and science etc
and the other side of this is that uh
what we are doing is practically useful
i
like systems like hammers or technically
guided
uh crm triggers are today
really used by by the verification
people
oh this is uh one slight overview of
what we are sort of doing today
so like i mentioned there is uh
various levels on which we can do things
so like i said the the most
established and i would say easy
uh on the engineering side
thing to do is to when you have a big
corpus
and you cannot feed it all to automate
ethereum viewers
to basically use some machine learning
film the proofs that you already know
and typically there are many proofs in
the corpus to
pre-select the lemmas for your next
proof attempt
so that that's that's called premise
selection and it's been
explored quite a bit in the uh
past i would say 15 years and it's a
established component of the hammer
systems today you you can also on this
very high level
use machine learning to to decide which
automated theorem proving strategy or
automated theorem prior to use or which
portfolio of strategies
so people have done machine learning for
that sort of thing too
you can you can also select something
called hints
which is a very good weapon for
solving uh some especially algebraic
uh problems um my automated theorem
previous so
but that's not done so much but uh
it's it's a very similar task as the
premise selection instead of
choosing directly the exams you are
choosing
what will what knowledge will be guiding
the proof search
through sort of the hints mechanism and
i will not go into it too much in this
talk
uh then there is the low-level guidance
so that that's really interesting
and i have been focusing and my group
has been focusing on that
let's say in the past four years quite a
lot
and i think they're really very
significant breakthroughs so
some five years ago uh we couldn't
improve neither well we couldn't improve
too much
uh neither like
the sort of vanilla simple systems
and we couldn't improve too much the
best automated here improvers
and the situation changed about two
years ago well one or two years ago
when we really basically did a
breakthrough by
putting very fast but very good machine
learning
into it and it suddenly started to work
and
it's it's it's in my opinion a turning
point where
even the the biggest opponents of
machine learning
in the automated tier and brewing
community basically have to agree
that the machine learning is beating
beating them today
and you you can you can also guide
uh crazy on a crazy
low level like guiding the kernel steps
in
in these um technical interactive
theorem previous that i call those whole
lcf style
theorem previous and some people have
tried it but but that seems to be really
too ambitious for all methods today
and the very reasonable thing to do like
i said is this
guiding of applications in the of
tactics in the
tactical here imperius so that's
probably
like at least in some cases these
systems are
today beating the hammer systems
and you can do inventions of atp
strategies for classes of problems and
conjectures and suitable concepts and
models you can you can do
theory exploration uh
which means basically developing
uh conjectures and theories by all sorts
of
inductive and deductive methods the the
very
cool thing that you can do is to
switch between proving and learning so
it's it's been like this learning slash
loop has been very productive i'll
show you some uh some data about it
and there's this auto formalization when
you basically
try to take a piece of latex and
translate it to a formal
math and again you can you can do it by
machine learning and assisted by
technology such as type checking and
theorem proving or disproving etc
so this is sort of the spectrum at least
to
some uh to some level
uh there there are many
corporate today like uh some of them
has been have been translated to like
the standard automated theorem proving
formats
uh for a long time some some of them are
it took longer to translate them for
example coke
is pretty challenging to translate to
for example first order logic so that it
gives you something so that it's not
unsound and incomplete or on something
incomplete too much
but basically there are really many many
benchmarks and you
you don't need to translate things down
to
some standard
automated theorem proving format anymore
today you can
really also uh people do it
play the game in the native logic
of the easier emperor like with these
tactical automated theorem previous
and obviously on this last line
there are also all these
informal or semi-formal corpora like
this prefiki
which is informal but um
sort of with some quite rigorous
structure the
the same for stacks for example so
stacks is much more
controlled than archive for example so
so again you can
you can sort of do various experiments
typically in
involving formalization but also just
some machine learning and
recommendation on these corporate
our demos okay uh so what should we
start with
i'll i'll show you the latest uh
see how i'm doing on time oops okay i
should go fast
uh so
uh we have been now for about half a
year
running a big evaluation on
on the mizard library which has
something like i'll
show you the top of of this github page
which is something like a 58
000 top-level problems
and basically we are doing the hammering
stuff
so we are trying
to use automated theorem previous
guided by machine learning together with
training premise selection which chooses
the relevant premises from
from the big corpus to to prove as many
of them
as possible and some of them are real
long like some of them have
like hundreds or some of them might have
even like 1 000 of lines
and in
2013 or 14 with cesari kalishik we could
prove
about 40 percent of them with the
premise selection
and 56 of them when we
used uh the human advice
for the premise selection so we
basically
took advice from the proof that was
already written
in in the missouri library and we just
wanted to sort of replay and that's
proof by
the automated crm preview so so
this last evaluation like we started
um using a learning version of e
recalled enigma that uses like gradient
booster trees
and um graph neural networks
uh and we are basically running this
proving and learning group
in in various ways both for the premise
selection
and for the internal guidance of the
automated preview of the epuri so you so
you can see
sort of how how the progress goes uh so
currently
the total of theorems we can prove is
something like 73.5 uh
five percent and what i wanted to show
you
is this uh how do i yeah um
am i there i might need to
do it again
okay yeah oh so so this this is the
pythagoras theorem so you have real
unitary space that some
well you can imagine vector space is
scalar
product in our product the product
whatever you call it
and oh maybe i'll click on this um
so yeah here everything is linked so you
have
two points or vectors in that space that
are orthogonal
and now you basically state the
pythagoras theorem so if you
take their sum and the norm squared
equals the norm of x plus norm of i
squared right and
and this is the sort of declarative
missile proof which
uh refers to various theorems in
in the library and like the definition
of orthogonality
like x and y orthogonal if their scalar
product equals zero
right or um x plus y
scalar product x plus lies is greater or
equal to zero because of the definition
of scalar
etc etc so you somehow draw draw
these theorems and definitions from the
library
and in some 15 lines you finish
this proof and we for a long time this
was too hard for our
automation automated technology but
finally
in may we we got
this proof so so this is the statistics
of
of the proof so it has 180
inference steps like these clause steps
initially the
proof contain 342
formulas axioms from the big misar
library which is something like kind of
100 000
uh statements in in it
it the the producer generated something
like 65
000 of new facts new new clauses
and all these clauses
are ranked by the machine learner as
they are generated
as you sort of infer between the axioms
and the generated facts
uh you you basically score or
rank all of them either by the gradient
boosted trees
or which was the case here or by the
graph neural networks that we have
inside inside enigma
and and based on that you you select
so-called
given clause or processed clause
which which are used for doing
inferences
with the previously selected clauses so
so that's a so-called
given clause algorithm which is like
basically the main
the strongest paradigm for automated
theorem proving today
uh so so you can see that of the let's
say
61 000 non-trivial generated clauses
we we have selected something like forty
four four thousand um clauses
for doing the inferences using
using the trained uh guidance and
uh the the guidance at this point was
trained on something like a half million
proofs
that were generated initially
just by running untrained improver which
gave us something like 15 000 proofs
then then training the guidance and then
solving more and more problems and also
solving the old ones more efficiently
and getting more and more proofs and
uh learning from them over and over so
so that's
uh how how we got to this thing that we
couldn't prove before
he here is yep yeah because you say like
that that's right you're showing us to
it but uh
the the the training set is produced by
the some sort of free generation of
proofs who was based times on corpus or
where did the training set come from
oh the the training stack set starts at
zero so you just have a 60 000
problems and you you run
them over with an untrained crm program
so
whatever is the state of the art in
automated your improving without
machine learning you just run
untrained improver with its best
strategies
and it gives you something so in 10
seconds it may give you something like
it has an ability to prove and that that
yeah
and and then you're giving it uh these
uh misar
uh statements of of lemmas just totally
exactly the fun they appear in the
library
oh no you you need a translation so so
from from that nice nicely looking stuff
which i was showing you
which is almost readable you translate
to tpdp
which is this stuff okay which
yeah yeah and that that can be read by
the automated theorem
okay so you're giving it that because
it's
okay yeah uh so
i i wanted to show you one more
so that there is a probably
oversimplified version
of carmichael's theorem
about fibonacci numbers
in the miser library which
is like one of the last theorems in in
that article
and it has a long proof so the proof is
something like 120 lines and
involves some limiting argument and some
induction argument and
uh so basically
what it says that if you if you have
uh two primes m and n
and m divides flip n like the nth
fibonacci number then if you have an
error that is small r that is smaller
than n
then m doesn't divide
uh fib air so fib r so so basically if
you
if you take any sort of smaller
fibonacci number
then mm will not divide this and
the the seams so so there is a theorem
called carmichael's theorem which is
more complicated and it seems that the
miser people sort of simplified it so so
that they could prove it
more easily but they probably
oversimplified it
and they they told me that they followed
a proof written by some
mathematician so so this is not their
product this is
their formalization of somebody else's
product but what happened
quite quite recently is
that basically the trained
machine learner found a much
simpler proof based on lemma which was
by the way solved by
bob soloway when he was struggling with
learning miser
which says that fibonacci mgcd fibonacci
n is fibonacci um gcdm
so so this is this is quite quite an
easy
lemma to to prove and
you you can really go very quickly for
for the dilemma
with the primality as assumptions to
to to show what these miser people were
trying
trying to show in a in a very long proof
that was in the library and it decided
to
to choose it as one of the were yeah
yeah yeah okay so this is a
this is a game that we have been playing
very long like it happened to me
first time in my phd seasons like 15
years ago actually
but you you really when you talk
about some human level intelligence
uh like my my first observation
is that what the premise selectors do
and it's irrelevant whether you use
simple machine learning or complicated
machine learning
they universally do things differently
than humans they see
they see wider and and they can do these
things
much more easily we have done it on the
flies by purpose we have done it on the
mizar cartoons we have done
on the isabel corpus so so
uh it's some sort of evidence that uh
what we are doing will not be totally
similar to humans basically
it will it will do some things better
than
some things uh worse i i think i'm
sort of pretty low on time uh so um
well these these uh demonstrations are
probably are a good way i think of
showing the state of things perhaps we
can see
another okay i'll show you some more
then yeah um
so so this is a miser hammer so i'll
i'm the hammer has been popularized by
larry paulsen in isabel
but you know i have created the miser
hammer so i
i did this video a long time ago so i
will show it to you
so so this is um
um miso proof saying that if a set x
is a subset of cardinal m then the
cardinality x is also a subset of the
cardinal
m and uh
the the miser proof proof checks
it's been written by a human and now i'm
basically removing
the references uh that were
supplied by the human to to make the
justifications of the steps
in the truth and i'm asking the hammer
and the hammer is sitting somewhere on
my server
in the netherlands at the time and doing
the premise selection for
from the big library uh by using
all sorts of machine learning on which
on
the library and using the trained models
and running the automated theorem
previous like like vampire and e3 on
that
and it's sort of coming back with the
reply so you can see
that the replies are quite different
from what the human put there
but once the once the hammer comes
back with that reply you you sort of
know
that this is something that you can use
so you can sort of post process it you
can you can prune
prune the proof but it basically to some
extent it works
as some verified advisor in the sense
that what it tells you is not incorrect
it's not
just some sort of machine learning
advice but it's a it's a verified
proof that it is proposing you so
especially in isabel did this
sort of mold of work when you are
calling the hammer in in the background
is really
very popular today so this is the
hammer demo and i'll show you
tebow go gs tactic tool so so that
that's a system
it's it's the first and so
for for a long time the only working uh
really usable system doing tactical
guidance of uh
of technical previous or learning-based
guidance of theorem series
so what he's doing is he's called
calling this
ttt tactic on the goal that he supplied
uh and it has loaded
uh 12 thousand tactics
and three thousand theorems and
it it has um pre-learned
on them so so it knows at this point
on which goals uh how to apply which
tactics during sort of the tactical
proof search
and it's it's doing some sort of monte
carlo style
uh search when it transforms the
original goal
by a tactic by by the most
likely or relevant tactic into another
goal or
list of goals and then it sort of
goes deeper and further tries to
basically discharge
those goals by other tactics uh
so uh that's uh
that's a system that as i said can
basically beat the hammer it's it's
performance is beating the hammer for a
whole floor
which has by the way been also done by
tebow
and one of the reasons for that is that
the hammers are not very good at high
order reasoning like
induction whereas um
what this tactical guiding systems are
doing is to some extent cheating
in the sense that they
take whatever algorithms whatever
tactical methods and procedures that
can be quite complicated programs are
already
present in the library and
there is quite a few of them because the
formalizers
program them in order to be efficient
so so when somebody like john harrison
programs a tactic
called induct you can bet that that
index
tactic is very well tuned
and designed for for the tasks in the
library
so so in some sense it's not
a big wonder that uh the sort of
technical guidance
works better than sort of a vanilla
automated theorem period
uh that even if it was complete for the
task if
it theoretically could be able to prove
the task
it it wasn't sort of too
much designed for for that particular
task
so that that's also why it really makes
a lot of sense to
to sort of do this mid-level
guidance for especially for the tactical
systems
and people have done it for for
other systems so i'll show you another
one for that's quite recent by
lassa wasserblaubruck so so it's
it's very similar in some sense to
tactic though it
also basically grows tactical proofs
so here he can basically
suggest a suitable hamas
for for the goal that he's proving and
it will just
tell him what he can use but in this
case there is nothing in the database
so he does the proof by himself and as
he does the proof when he gets to the
second goal
there is already something in the
database so when he when he will call
suggest here it will suggest something
useful
you can see the ranking of the tactics
that he can use here
and when he says search it will actually
finish finish the tactical proof for him
so here you can
you can see the tactical proof so so
this has been now done i think the
google people have done it for a whole
lot
uh i think that there are people
thinking about doing it for
lina et cetera so it's it's a thing that
makes a lot of sense for the tactical uh
theorem this is the last demo
showing you some sort of auto
formalization it's quite an old one
so this is not deep learning this is uh
probabilistic context free grammars
so we we take something which looks
quite informal
it's it's not exactly latex it's sort of
but it's also not for momma and we
run it through a trained probabilistic
context free
parser the parser is trained
on many examples of the informal thing
uh coupled to to the proper
disambiguation to the
formal thing and on top of that when we
get like because it's non-deterministic
when when
we get multiple parses we take
the most plausible ones and we basically
give them
to the whole light hammer and
the whole lighthammer looks at the whole
whole light
knowledge base and does the hammering
thing
and tries to prove those particular
uh disambiguations or formalizations of
of these um uh of these informal
statements so so
so this is like i i don't think we
have a working fully working auto
formalization system
working on some arbitrary latex or
whatever but this
is sort of a first step in in that
direction okay so i'm done with the
demos
and now the question is what i do in the
next 10 minutes
price selection i think i have said
quite a bit about it so
uh yeah these are the hammer systems
made popular
in isabel the the success rate we could
get some
five six years ago was 40 to 45 percent
the miracle which happened some three
four years ago
is that cesari kalishik and luka shaika
could actually make it
get a decent performance also on the coc
standard library
which uses which is very distant from
standard first level logic
so that was quite surprising to me and
quite nice
and what i was showing now like is that
we are getting to something like 60
percent
on on the miser data basically thanks
thanks a lot to to strong internal
guidance of the automated theorem
previous to to
serve this enigma enigma systems
uh so there is a lot to say about the
various
methods that people have used for
premise selection
so the questions are how do you
characterize mathematical formulas like
by
some symbols or by some more semantic
features
uh what machine learning methods you use
like
actually a simple distance weighted k
near sniper
is is a like baseline that is very hard
to beat
uh but there are state-of-the-art
methods like gradient boosted decision
trees or
graph neural networks that are pretty
competitive
and typically improve on
the k on the simpler methods
then it's interesting to apply
like stateful uh
for example neural methods like
recurrent neural methods and
transformers
which so so all the previous methods
sort of look at uh
at just the conjecture and the relevance
of some formula or premise in the big
knowledge base to the conjecture well
the
stateful methods like current neural
networks can do is that when they
propose the first premise
they change their state and um
based on that they recommend the next
premise so
you can compare it to how recurrent
neural networks are used
to to do machine translations like once
you have decided
uh to do the translation in some way the
recurrent neural network sort of ensures
your internal consistency and
grammatical consistency of the
of the translated statement so so in the
sense
these are relatively interesting methods
to use and
we are getting quite interesting results
from them
and what you obviously always can do in
machine learning is to combine
all the different methods that's called
the ensemble methods and and that
typically also gives you additional
additional performance i will
not go into this because that film
[Music]
running so so you can see how isolated
this field was back in 2006 because i
have boldly called it machine iron for
automated reasoning
it's like oh
so so it um what it does
is um this sort of infinite feedback
loop
between solving a large number of
problems in
in some corpus which are somehow related
and learning from the solution so so
in in this case uh the machine learner
was
learning the premise selection task how
to how to choose
uh the the most relevant premises for
proving
the particular conjectures and this game
has been
played over and over since since then so
we have for example this
adp boost system by bartosz petrovsky
and these are some graphs showing you
the
the sort of learning slash proving group
on a particular
smallish missouri mptp data set
where uh in each round we basically
increase the number of proof problems
and the red line is the k near sniper
and the the better lines
are these gradient booster trees these
xg boost
methods and and these lines are
growing sort of much more linearly than
than this sort of logarithmic
growth and they show you the number of
proofs so so even
even if we cannot um prove more theorems
we can still come up with
alternative proofs so that's quite
interesting in this
and there's many many iterations and
this is some histogram of of the uh
how many proofs we have for which
uh theorems low level guidance so
let me try to do at least that so so
the the simplest theorem i could think
of
like some ten years ago was this lingo
which is a minimalistic
uh tableau tableau preview uh
which which is really which can be
implemented in i don't know like the
core algorithm
is like 15 lines of prologue
and it constructs this tableau which is
basically a
proof tree by by some sort of
extension and reduction steps and
so we we have been trying to use
this partially produced tree as
a characterization of the proof state
and and based on the true state we would
advise
which action which of these clauses to
apply
to to to the proof state so so it's it's
a very nice setting because the
proof state is quite compact unlike
in those state-of-the-art big resolution
superpositions title style previews
so we have tried several times the first
system was
machine learning connection preview then
we did a fairly efficient one called
female cop and then
some three years ago we were impressed
by the
alphago alpha zero uh thing
by d pint and we have decided to do
exactly what they did like modulo the
single player versus two two players
and we put the monte carlo research in
into that
and also quite strong clearness like
these gradient
boosted trees and what we are doing is
to
for for the state to learn the policy
like which clause you should
you should choose and also the value of
the state like
is is the state going to lead to and
that
uh i'll skip this really that was like
uh first a pretty good breakthrough in
in this internal guidance
because in something like
eight iterations we could
uh go
from oh five iterations
uh we could go from something like
eleven
hundred views to something like sixteen
hundred views which
is a pretty pretty big improvement
uh in in the theorem curving field
so um so so that that was
that was like a first sign that the
methods are starting to work and
um i would say we were encouraged by all
sorts of people to do deep learning but
deep learning was so slow compared to
the igradian boosted trees
that um we basically couldn't
couldn't make it reasonably very in some
reasonable
time limits at that time we we sort of
made it work later
uh so so the this sort of toy theorem
period
has been used since for quite a lot of
experiments
by other people so so there is flop
which uses curriculum learning on
basically a single proof
one times one equals one to to learn
like multiplication in the arithmetic
domains
and that that's very interesting and
then there are all these
incarnations like pl code the gn and cop
very
actually put the graph neural network
into it and it started to do something
michael rossen has a lazy cop and joel
zumba is trying
to learn explainable prologue actions
slash tactics from from the two traces
so so
this this is quite a nice environment
for
playing with a simple cooler and
combining with this
machine and reinforcement learning the
the biggest thing
i already advertised so so it's this
guidance
of state-of-the-art automated theorem
period
like improver which has
which it doesn't doesn't have the notion
of state like like this simple tableau
but it has these two large heaps of
clauses the process
and on process clauses and you sort of
have to do something with it you have to
decide how
what will you learn on so what we learn
on
are the clauses used in the proof and
the negative examples
are the clauses chosen by the theorem
period which however
didn't vary use in the proof so these
are some sort of hard
hard negatives for it for you and the
uh like yanakubu is the main developer
uh with gradient boosted trees
and very recently graph neural networks
efficient graph neural networks
by miracle shock which are sort of logic
oriented so we for example heart codes
negation can
really do uh quite nice iteration so so
we have this 70 percent improvement
where we on the mesa corpus we start
with 15 000 proofs
and in uh i don't know how many
uh seven or what iterations
of of learning and proving uh we get
from this 15 000 to the
25 000. i think i'm two minutes over
time mike so
i should probably shut up okay i mean if
you have a
conclusion slide you can share that but
uh
oh yeah so so martin surah has done this
recently for the vampire so
it's it's the ultimate automated theorem
preview
i have already mentioned tactic tool so
i can this
this was also a demo the
what i probably missed is this symbolic
uh task done with neural networks so it
started with bartos pyeotrovsky and he
basically
learns normalization of polynomials or
algebraic rewrite rules with
recurrent neural networks and
transformers and you have probably all
seen
the follow-up work by facebook on
integration etc so that that's quite
interesting
uh thibault yeah has a nice
reinforcement deep reinforcement
learning toolkit for synthesis
so here i come back to the question in
the beginning so
so he synthesizes combinators for a
given lambda expression or
the funtime equation for a given set
and the ultimate goal is to learn
argument synthesis for technical theorem
improving
and yella pipenbrook is going to submit
that paper very soon
where he really greatly improves the
reinforcement learning and this i think
so this is basically a teaser
and then there is this whole
conjecturing thing
that sort of slightly exploded last year
uh where people basically started to use
transformers
like like i'm truly guilty of so so here
here is a sort of a proof
generated by by gpt2 which was
run forever on the mizar library and if
you
if you are not familiar with miser you
will probably believe
so this actually type checks so it's
it's not
it's a proof you can if you
understand the semantics
you will see that the gpt 2 is doing
totally wrong steps
but they look very convincing so so this
has been
taken up by for example open ai running
these
experiments on training a crazy crazy
big
gpt etc and actually we do
sometimes generate interesting
conjectures so for example we
generalized theorem about groups
where the finiteness uh condition isn't
needed
but we just couldn't prove it because it
was too hard for the automation
so that's it i will skip the
out of formalization oh there is no
conclusion
um let me just show you that this is
quite fun
so when you when you do neural network
sort of auto formalization in the sense
that you have on one side
latex and on the other side formal math
in this case misar
uh this is what you can do you can
watch the predictions of the neural
network as it
is being trained so so
this is the correct statement in misar
and this this is the input latex and you
can see that
the the output of the neural network
when it's not much strength is total
but then already here it focuses
much better and by snapshot 7000
it basically generates something that is
alpha equivalent
to to the correct statement it's
equivalent up to the renaming of
variables
so how is it being trained oh so so i
i took the full misaricorpos not just
the top level theorems but
all the lines which is something like
one one million lines
and there is a translator to latex from
that
so so in some sense the latex is
synthesized
so so it's not through human written
latex it's synthesized from
from the formal text and that gave me
one million training examples
on which i just ran some standards
google nmt toolkit neural machine
translation toolkit
which was basically
used for training english to vietnamese
or english to french
and and that's it i mean i i didn't
train it my phd student
sean wong trained it uh well what was
also quite interesting in this
experiment
so sean sean was sort of learning on
that and we found out
that what really made a lot of
difference in
in these tasks is a mechanism called
attention which you probably
some of you at least have heard about so
the performance of the
recurrent neural network without
attention was quite a bit worse than
the performance of the new matrix with
uh
with attention on these tasks uh
so the this is this is just a teaser for
you to to show you that
it's not completely hopeless like some
people believed like
five ten years ago and even
if they're connected to a machine or
neural network or some other machine
learner
doesn't get it perfectly quite often
you can do something with it so i think
sort of the path to auto formalization
is is a pretty interesting
thing to pursue today so that could be
the conclusion
here are some acknowledgments to all
sorts of people who are today working on
that
and some references and here is my
advertisement so
this year we actually managed to have
some hybrid aitp
in oswa and you are accordingly invited
to
come next september to osua or
at least participate remotely
on this conference workshop
which is pretty informal and discussion
oriented
called artificial intelligence and fear
and viewing
thanks for your attention thanks thanks
yes
take questions from the audience
yeah can you can you explain
the type system that you used
in the
type system do you mean some
so there are various type systems for
various uh interactive theorem previous
well in any of those examples you
had a lot of demonstrations from github
so what is
the type system in there uh in the miser
examples
you mean things like yeah for example
here yeah
oh okay oh so that's an invention
of the miser people it's called a soft
soft typing system so from the point of
view of the
sort of foundational type systems it's
actually not
a type system it's basically
a way of treating first order predicates
and providing automation for that so
basically every missile type like for
example prime
is um is um
is a predicate and what you
oh actually this is um this is not a
good example let me try
not here um yeah
so net is an actual number and
um it's it's a predicate saying that
a is a natural if it is in omega
and so so you can when you are
translating to first cell logic you can
very easily expand or misr types
to to first order predicates well what
miser does for you
automatically are these type inferences
that are called registrations in misart
so for example here you register the
fact that omega is a non-empty order
so so whenever uh
mizar sees this symbol or
function omega it will automatically
derive
the predicate non-empty and predicate
ordinal about
it so so you have a lot of these typing
hierarchies
uh in in some
systems like for example in isabel there
is a related system called type classes
so it's it's also not like a
foundational type system
but it's something on top of the
foundational system
that basically propagates the predicates
that
hold about your object
thanks christian your hand is up would
you like to
yes sorry let me just try to
uh yeah okay so yeah i
just have a like a meta question on so
let's see if you could pick one
like itp or a
system like wizard or whole or whatever
to do autoformalization what would be
your first choice
i made a choice 20 years ago because
mizar was
sort of very friendly to me as a guy who
only knew first all the logic and set
theory
um and it was also designed by a
linguist like
andre tribulus among other things was a
linguist who
had really a lot of focus on on these
readable groups so i think
some ten nine years ago i
i was completely surprised i was
organizing a workshop on mathematical
wikis in my machine
collocated with the itb conference and i
have invited
the guy behind the proof wiki
and it looked like he totally
independently
arrived even though profic is sort of
informal
at a very similar proof style like the
mizar
mizar guys so uh so
my for for the auto formalization
one of the things i was sort of
nudging my phd students to do
was to was to go between prufiki and
mizar
and i actually even had one
researcher working for me who was a
mizar mizar guy
and he was aligning the proofs
between prufiki so in some sense
i do have a corpus of informal
and math in perfectly aligned
uh with mizar to to some extent
what what i would also um so we have
also played this fly spec quite a bit
but the
that there it sort of probably works on
the level of formulas because
you like tom hills has been quite nice
in
explaining how how the fly spec informal
proofs correspond to the formal proofs
but the tactical proofs are sort of
unusable
and unreadable for humans
so so that that's a big um negative
uh so i would uh like
i already did basically uh chose mizai
for that
but i i would say any
any system is declarative proofs like
uh isabel for example has a big archive
of formal proofs
and some of it is not declarative some
of it uses sort of the old technical
language but
a lot of it is sort of written in this
sort of misari
mizar declarative 2 style and i believe
there are even books that has been
formalized by the isabel people
and i haven't looked at the proofs but
i i would bet that there might be
uh interesting parts of the formal
proofs that
reasonably correspond to some books so
that
might be one one thing uh to look at
um on the other hand like so
we have done i i didn't have time to go
into it we have done
also experiments with unsupervised
machine learning which is sort of the
next big thing in in machine translation
and i since i have seen it
so this was like two years ago i
i i sort of started to believe that we
actually don't need so much aligned
corporate
for this task so i i think
i i'm happy that we did the experiments
on on the big
sort of aligned corpus generated from
isr even though it's synthetic
but i i think the
the future is really bright in the sense
that we will not need
too much aligned corporate for this
all right it's just as a thanks uh
this is a a general question i mean uh
you you
each of your experiments of course you
have to work with a particular system so
you did quite a bit with misara and
you discussed some results of other
systems and then how much
work would it be to repeat an experiment
say for example we have this big
lead method and we wanted to do a
comparable
so i i think it's it's become sort of
routine
like uh so um
so ever since joe herrera and larry
paulson and his collaborators
did the sort of hammered translation for
hall
and isabelle uh and then
luka shaika and cesari kalishik did the
hammer translation for
i think and and ever since like
um people so so the very contact
like to do it right to really make it
work the engineering issues with the
tactical guidance i
really there is it looks it looks simple
on one slide but it's two years of
typical phd phd work and the same for
the tactician for la sabre blob rooks
works for coco
so if if you are talking about the
hammer systems
it's it's probably not so hard to do
some translation for lean
following for example what has been
known for if you
if you are talking about the tactical
systems
then it really depends on the design
of the internal levels of the system
like how
how friendly it is to do something like
tactic toe and tactician are doing you
you may get in trouble so for example
lasse got in trouble
with some mona inside inside and it
took him a while and it's still not
completely solved and he may need some
collaboration from the cog developers to
to improve on that
but i would say the advantage of lean
is that at least my impression is that
it's still a system which is very much
in development
and leo leomora isn't afraid to
completely
change everything from version 2 to
version 3 or
whatever it is so i think if you
if you get reasonable support from the
developers to do
something like tactic though then that
would be what i would try to do
and at least what i hear is that they
are
having this sort of meta programming uh
framework there which might be something
to look at
but i'm not really a lean expert so i
uh yeah
here's a really very open question for
you which
then maybe i don't know what kind of
answer one could give at this point so
one
you know especially with uh you know
alphago and
alpha zero you know one had just
steaming quantum leap and the
capabilities of machine learning and ai
and
uh so is it just a matter of uh
unpredictable time before we see a
similar quantum leap for ai and they're
improving or is
a ion through improving obviously harder
in some way we can bend down or
do we do we have any idea yeah
i i would like to know so uh you you
could
probably sense that i got myself so so
what is really nice is that sometimes
you really get surprised by these two so
for example this enigma
we were getting some improvements
like ten percent or whatever but then
one day we simply trained it like hell
and we
ran several iterations on enough data
and it started it gave us this crazy 70
percent improvement and does the
question of
what what improved what was the
improvement does that question could
that question have any answer
so the specific case so so i would say
it was a combination of a good
and fast machine learner uh
so
the fact that it was fast meant that
we really can
do a lot of these proving
slash learning loops and that gives us a
lot of data
to learn from and that seems to be
important so so for example after that
uh my phd students are gersol did an
experiment
with completely stupid improver he
totally removed all heuristics
which the theorem proving people have
been inventing for many years
and he just trained it he just
overtrained it and he
he made it better than than the best
human human written heuristic just just
by the machine learning
so so so this is a partial answer
well these are two partial answer
answers to the question like one one is
that that this is sort of behaving quite
unpredictably like
some things don't work for a long time
and then suddenly
you you make them work and the the other
answer is that there is this sort of
alphago alpha zero approach
where you just sort of do do some
of these iterations and you are hoping
that you will
gradually reach bigger and bigger proofs
and
you will learn whatever the human might
think about or the neural network will
generalize so well that it will
even generalize to unseen cases
uh and it's
it's it's doing something it's
definitely helped
but um i think that the problem
even with alphago alpha zero is the
basically it doesn't transfer
so if you give the trained network
a goal board which is twice as big it
will
it will be stupid so so a lot of
also the transformer based results for
example we
like bartosz petrovsky got a bit annoyed
by the facebook people so sort of
scooping him
when they did this integration uh so he
looked at their data set and he saw
that the date the training data are
extremely saturated and the testing data
set
is is sort of after some modifications
very similar to what is in the training
data so
in a lot of these methods you see
a lot of memorization and very limited
algorithmic learning so for example the
inductive logic programming which i was
doing my master's thesis
is really about learning explainable
algorithms and non-trivial algorithms
and i i don't see the current neural
architectures to do that so for example
if you are a mathematician you can
eventually come up
with something like gaussian elimination
and there is no way for the current
architectures to
to come up with such non-trivial
algorithms
so i i think we
i like i i totally believe that the open
ai and facebook people
will saturate their data sets to to the
level
that they will be claiming that we have
reached some grand master level in
mathematics
but but i think we we need sort of
more advanced algorithmic uh learning
to to really uh do do the things that
the mathematicians are doing
the the saturation or by
a lot of data will definitely give us
something and it will
it already is fairly useful like i can
prove
uh whatever some version of carmichael's
theorem
i can prove very long theorems in misai
so so it's really useful and you know
the humans aren't so good right like
let's face it
but um for a lot of mathematics is
invention
of algorithms and i don't think of
non-trivial algorithms
non-continuous algorithms so so it's
even questionable how much
the continuous optimization methods can
can take us there
like how much we don't have to do some
let's say evolutionary methods for
example
let me let me throw out another general
question i mean uh
you know if i sit back and i i i think
it's fair to say here your talk is a
computer science and not mathematics you
know it's it's definitely uh
methods and uh one's learning a lot and
making great advances
but are there points in in your work
where you wish you had
you could imagine ways that
mathematicians could contribute so so
for example one obvious answer is yes
they can
continue to develop these libraries of
formal mathematics they can serve as
training data but but are there
otherwise
yeah good question how could
mathematicians contribute
so so one one thing uh so for example
tom hales
has this formal abstract project which
is quite a bit
what you just mentioned right but uh
it's not
it's not asking the mathematicians to
fully write the proofs
it's just asking them to try to
formalize the statements or
abstracts in lean and
then already that
would be pretty useful and i think
not just for our research it would also
be useful for mathematicians because it
would
allow them to search semantically
and do things things like that so so
that's one very clear point and
everybody should join tom in writing
formal abstracts
but tim gowers gave a nice talk
three years or four three and a half
years ago
at the big proof conference in cambridge
where he was sort of showing on an
example from imo from the mathematical
olympics
how he's sort of following his nose
and doing some things and not doing some
things
and i think i well he he made a
statement which i disagreed with which
was like
i can get a programmer to program
program these things and i i said well
you you cannot
this this approach has failed a long
time ago and i'm not sure if i convinced
him
so so but yeah the argument is that you
need
some automated learning at least that
that's what i believe in that you sort
of
shouldn't be programming these things
explicitly but training systems that
learn those rules but uh what
what he was showing was very instructive
and they they're very high level
explanations of what he was showing
so uh i guess
we may be able to learn from
such things in the future and well what
is
maybe also pretty useful are these
things like the stacks
stacks project which are um
also sort of going in the direction of
some semi
semi formalization which makes it easy
for us to
try to detect the definitions for
example or the
references so uh maybe one
one request to mathematicians is don't
write crazy latex uh try to
like for example the stacks format is
really
nice for the computer scientists to
process and to do
autoformalization experiments on that
much much more like
than on the full archive uh
corpus uh but like this idea
of coming up basically
of this high temperature to low
temperature
uh where we would have
um some
tool chain or some series of
levels uh which we could gradually
attack um sounds quite interesting
and something that where the
mathematicians could help
right like um ideally like they would
for example be
interacting with some learning and
proving system where
they would say something sort of
minimalistic that they are
telling to the student and then
well maybe the system is too low level
for that
well then the mathematician would
explain in the more low level language
and at the same time try to explain
what he meant by the high level concept
or
trick or method right so
i i can imagine that uh the methods will
come
that will that will also be capable of
learning in in this way in this sort of
uh explain me the math and i do not
understand what you are saying
so uh that that's yeah
that's probably pretty awake at the
moment okay but it's an inspiring uh
idea more questions from the audience
[Music]
so do you think it's possible to map a
mazar type
system to the types that are used on
archive papers for example an algebra
for example what
i cannot hear you
wait we can't hear you i i don't know
what would be
the type system for archive
uh your your muted uh standard
standard
okay uh no uh okay i i don't know i mean
uh
more questions or uh
we uh we'll we'll have uh several more
uh
talks on this topic and so it'll be
interesting to perhaps uh come back and
discuss
uh you know these are very open-ended
questions
but uh let's thank uh usf for a very
enlightening uh survey and uh a lot of
interesting
work and uh so
next week we'll be having uh christian
zegaty
who will speak about uh language models
as
mathematical models at the same time so
i
look forward to seeing you all then
thanks everybody
thank you bye bye thank you